[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم في حلقه جديده من برنامجكم
الندوه اليوم نناقش في هذا الصالون موضوع
مباشر وسهل جدا لكنه في نفس الوقت خطير
وله اثاره في المستقبل وفي الحاضر كما ان
له جذوره في الماضي هل تصلح الانظمه
الجمهوريه لنا نحن في العالم العربي
والاسلامي فكره اننا نستنسخ النموذج
الغربي باحزابه بدوراته الانتخابيه كل
اربع سنوات بمواسمه بصراع الاحزاب الى
اخره وايضا بالتداول على راس هرم السلطه
اما ان ذلك
ثوب لا يصلح لنا
وعباءه قد لا تناسب
ظروفنا واحوالنا نقول ذلك بعد مضيء ما
يكفي من السنوات عقود من السنوات لتجربه
الانظمه الجمهوريه في العالم العربي بل
وفي العالم الاسلامي اليوم بعد ان استفحل
الداء وكثير من هذه الدول مزقتها الحروب
الاهليه
الفتن الداخليه او
الانسداد السياسي يرى البعض ان وجود
الانظمه الملكيه هو الحل الامثل على الاقل
كظامنه للاجماع الوطني وعلى فكره هذا
الكلام مش محصور فقط في العالم العربي حتى
في العالم الاسلامي يعني مثلا عندنا
مناداه في ايران اليوم لعوده الشاه من
جديد كما ان الامر نفسه في عوده النظام
الملكي في افغانستان بعد اسقاطه واسقاط
الملك ظاهر شاع عام 1973 معنى للنقاش هذا
الامر تقليب اوراقه لننظر اي صواب فيه واي
خطا معنا وشركائنا في ندوه اليوم هنا في
الاستوديو والاستاذ منيف عماش الحربي
المحلل السياسي السعودي
والكاتب المتعدد الاتجاهات كما معنى من
الرباط الاستاذ عادل بن حمزه
وارحب بكم في هذه الندوه الموجزه ابدا معك
استاذ عادل بن حمزه لفت انتباهي مقاله
كتبتها في جريده النهار اللبنانيه عن عوده
النظام الملكي في ليبيا او امكانيات عوده
النظام الملكي في ليبيا هلا حدثتنا عن هذه
المقاله ولماذا كتبتها
اولا شكرا على الاستضافه وشكرا على طرح
هذا الموضوع الذي اعتقد بانه يستحق ان
يكون وان يحظى بالنقاش في هذه المرحله من
تطور العالم العربي فيما يتعلق فيما يرجع
الى المقاله بطبيعه الحال انا متابع لليبي
بحكم الانتماء الى المنطقه المغاربيه
وايضا بحكم تتبعي الى اثار
الربيع العربي على كثير من الدول بطبيعه
الحال ليبيا منذ 2011 وهي يعني تراوح
مكانها فيما يتعلق بالبحث عن حل
للوضع الحالي لانه مع الاسف العقيد معمر
القذافي لم ينشئ دوله بعد انقلاب على
الملك ادريس سنوسي بل انشا حتى مؤسسه
الجيش التي كان يمكن ان تكون رابطا وجامعا
فكك مؤسسه الجيش وانشا ميديشيات يقودها
ابناؤه ومناصره ما لفت انتباهي وان العامل
الذي شكل موضوع وحده لانه التيارات التي
شاركت في ثوره 17 17 فبراير ليبيه كانت من
مشارب مختلفه امتيارات سياسيه مختلفه هناك
ليبراليين هناك
اليساريين هناك ايضا جزء من الاسلام
السياسي اذا كان هناك تيارات متعدده لكن
لافت ان العامل الذي شكل وحده بكل هذه
التيارات المتناقضه كان هو العوده الى
عالم المملكه الليبيه فشكل علم المملكه
الليبيه بالوانه الثلاث التي تشير وترمز
الى مناطق الثلاث فزان
وبرقه وطرابلس
شكل عامله واحده ومنطلقا لتوحيد الجهود في
مواجهه نظام العقيد معمل القذافي وبقايا
نظامه في اطار ثوره فبراير ايضا العوده
الى نشيد الاستقلال سنه 19 مع انشاء
المملكه السنوسيه الليبيه سنه 1951 اذا
بالعوده الى ثم ان التطورات التي عرفتها
لي لليوم هناك كثير من الاصوات التي
ارتفعت اولا بعوده النظام الملكي ايضا
لتوحيد هذه المناطق التي كانت تاريخيا
دائما منقسمه وقد نجح الملك ادريس سنوسي
في توحيدها في مرحله سابقه وايضا هناك
النقاش حول المرجعيه والارضيه الدستوريه
لبناء لكي يتم البناء عليها في المستقبل
وكانت من بين الوثائق التي تم الاشاره
اليها نبيل الفرقاء وهو دستور المملكه
الليبيه 1951 وهو بالمناسبه كان دستورا
متقدما بالنظر الى ما كان سائدا في
المنطقه في تلك الفتره اذا كان هذا هو
المنطلق وخاصه في المراحل الانتقاليه كيف
يمكن ان تكون العوامل المشتركه وكيف ان
يكون لثقل التاريخ عاملا يؤسس لوحده وطنيه
يمكن البناء عليها اذن هذا هو المنطلق
الذي كان فيما يتعلق هذا هذا منطلق يصلح
للتاسيس عليه في النقاش وساعود اليك استاذ
عادل بعد قليل التوقف عن بعض النقاط لكن
اسال الاستاذ منيف
سؤال مباشر هل يمكن لبلد زال منه النظام
الملكي ومضى على زواله عقود من السنين
يعني تتكلم هذه الانظمه اغلبها بعضها ازيل
في الخمسينات مثل النظام الملكي المصري
مثل النظام الملكي العراقي بعده وبعضها في
السبعينات مثل النظام
الايراني والنظام الافغاني هل يمكن عوده
هذه الانظمه
شكرا استاذ مشاري وشكرا على الوضوح
للموضوع نعم
في ظني انه في الشرق الاوسط هناك نوعين من
النظام الملكي نظام الملكي اللي تاسس بعد
مؤتمرستيفالي وانشاء الدوله الوطنيه 1648
اللي
ظهر في الدوله السعوديه الاولى وهو انشاء
دوله مملكه وخاصه بعد محمد بن سعود عبد
العزيز محمد انشا دوله اذا تاخذ خريطه
1814 ترى انه الدوله السعوديه الاولى هي
الوازنه مع الدوله التجاريه
والعثمانيين وهي العاصمه الملكيه الاولى
للعالم العربي هذه الانظمه الملكيه التي
تنشا من بيئتها يعني محمد الامام محمد بن
سعود اتى من بيئته وتراكم تاريخي ثم انشا
نظام الملكيه وهذا النظام الملكي استمر
بدليل بعد سقوط الدرعيه عاد النظام الملكي
السعودي مره اخرى في الدوله السعوديه
الثانيه ثم عاد في الدوله السعوديه
الثالثه لانه هذا نظام ملكي اتى من بيئته
وهناك عقد اجتماعي وله شرعيته وهذا يستمر
دائما بدليل دول الخليج يعني دول الخليج
في كل المراحل في الكويت استمر نظام
الملكي في الامارات هذا النموذج السعودي
يستمر دائما لانه ابن بيئته النظام الاخر
الملكي كان نظاما مستوردا مستعمرا
مفروضه بالقوه يعني الملكيه المصريه لم
تكن ملكيه مصريه فعليا هي ملكيه البانيه
تركيه وبالتالي سقطت ولن تعود من الصعب ان
تعود ايضا الملكيه العراقيه المالكيه
مستورده بريطانيا قررت اتخاذ في سوريا
كانت مؤقته لمده
1918 الى
المتوكليه في اليمن نفس الطريقه رفضت فهذا
النموذج لا ياتي من فئه بس انا لاحظت
ملاحظه على فكره في المقارنه الانظمه مثل
لفتات الانتباه الاشاره الى الدوله
السعوديه الاولى
ومضى ثمانين عام في الدوله السعوديه
الاولى مرحله الغياب تقريبا اربع سنوات
وعاد الامام تركي واسسست دوله يعني على
اختلاف بين الباحثين لان تركي دخل اكثر من
مره للرياض لكن الانظمه اللي اللي ازيلت
الملكيه كانت فتره بسيطه يعني الشاه شاعره
شاه والابن شاه رضا بهلوي وابنه محمد رضا
بهلوي فقط افغانستان كذلك يعني شبك من
جذور هذه العائلات بس اقصد النظام كنظام
ملكي هو فقط امان الله خان
حتى الليبيا استاذ عادل هو فقط الملك
ادريس يعني لم يتعاقب اكثر من ملك بينما
مثلا نجد النظام الملكي المغربي معرق في
الزمن وقديم جدا يعني الاسره العلويه في
المغرب قديمه جدا وقبلها هي ورثه اصلا
الاسره السعوديه اللي كانت ايضا من نفس
الاروما العلويه او كذا يعني قصدي مضى
عليه عده قرون فهل فهل الزمن عام الجوهري
في ترسيخ وتكريس النظام الملكي في التربه
السياسيه يؤثر في ديمومته او في امكانيه
استعادتها ام لا يعني
استاذ عادل
اسبانيا هي التي استطاعت ان توحد من جديد
اسبانيا واستطاعت الى اليوم ان تواجه كل
تحديات انفصاليه نتذكر قبل سنوات ما حدث
في كتالونيا وكيف واجهت الحكومه المركزيه
استنادا الى ما يمنح الدستور وما يثبت
الوحده الوطنيه اذا هناك اشكالات كثيره
فيما يتعلق بالعوده الى تاريخ الملكيات
ومقارنتها مع الانظمه الجمهوريه لابد ان
نتذكر ان هذه الانظمه لم تستمر فتره طويله
مثلا في مصر بين 1922 1952
في ليبيا 1951 الى 1969
في اليمن
1918 الى 1962
بصفه عامه عندما نقارن زمن الملكيات في
المنطقه العربيه مقارنه مع الانظمه
الجمهوريه ان الانظمه الجمهوريه عاشت
لفتره طويله وبالتالي لم تقدم كل الاجوبه
الاقتصاديه والتنمويه والديمقراطيه فيما
يتعلق بالشعوب والانتظارات شعوب العربيه
يعني تريد العادل ان هذه الانظمه انظمه
الجمهوريه اخذت حقها من الوقت الذي تمتحن
فيه وبالتالي لم تثبت هي انها عقود يعني
بعضها الان
لم تثبت
جدارتها على عكس الانظمه الملكيه التي
اخذت فتره قصيره جدا وبالتالي لم تاخذ
حقها من الوقت سنعود لنقاش هذه النقطه اذا
تاذن لاستاذ منيف واستاذ عادل ولكن بعد
فاصل وجيز فلا تذهبوا عنا بعيدا في
التطواف بين ادغال التاريخ وتاريخ
الملكيات
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد موضوعنا هو نقاش
الحنين للملكيات في العالم العربي في
الدول التي رحل منها هذا النظام خاصه
الدول التي تعاني من انسداد في الافق
السياسي والنزاعات اهليه
واحترابات سياسيه البعض بعض النخب ولا
اقول الكل بدا يفكر في ماذا لو قارنا
وضعنا الحالي في الوضع الذي كنا عليه او
كان اجدادنا عليه ايام الانظمه الملكيه
وتم الثوره على هذه الانظمه بدعوى جلب
نظام مدني سياسي جديد ومفيد وعصري وحديث
يشابه او يضارع الانظمه الغربيه
الليبراليه الاوروبيه اليوم يتم امتحان
هذه المقوله وهي صحيحه ام لا بالعوده الى
تذكر عهود الانظمه الملكيه شركاء
الندوكانو وما زالوا من المغرب الاستاذ
عادل بن حمزه من الرباط تحديدا وهنا في
الرياضه الاستاذ منيف عماش الحربي
الباحث السياسي
هنا قبل الفاصل كنا نناقش ان الانظمه
الجمهوريه اخذت حقها من الوقت يعني تتكلم
في الخمسينات بعضها يعني
في مصر مثلا او في ليبيا في اواخر
الستينات وبالتالي الحصاد ما كان كما طبعا
مع التفاوت ولا نريد ان نضع مقارنه واحده
لان هذا في ظلم في انجازات يعني في
انجازات حصلت لبعض الانظمه خاصه في مصر
لكن نتكلم مثلا عن ليبيا اليوم على الاقل
مصر مستقره ودوله متماسكه لكن ليبيا اليوم
دوله تعيش في حاله احترام ولا ندري هل هل
يستمر هذا الاتحاد
ام لا هل ترى ان الزمن نستاذ منيف يشفع
للانظمه الملكيه المنجزات الزمنيه او
الانظمه الجمهوريه تختلف من دوله هي دوله
موتشو كان يقول انه تشكل السياسي نظام
السياسي مبني على ثلاثه
الجغرافيا طبيعه الارض والمناخ والعادات
والتقليد لو تحضر ليبيا بين السنوسي وسيف
الاسلام القذافي تجد الكفته راجحي لسيف
الاسلام القذافي لانه هناك في حنين لهذا
في العراق لو تاتي بين الملكيه العراقيه
او نظام صدام حسين الحنين لنظام صدام حسين
اكبر في تونس لما تتكلم على النظام الملكي
اللي كان قبل الحبيب بورقيبه او نظام ابن
علي وبرقيبه الحنين عند التوانسه الاغلبيه
هو الحنين لنظام ابن علي لانه ابن علي
2010 كان الدوله الاولى في التنميه لا
تستطيع في العالم العربي ان تقول هناك
وصفه معينه لنظام الحكم يتشكل بلا شك انه
يعني تونس في حنين كبير لعوده ابن علي
لانه كان مستقل الله يرحمه كان مستقر لانه
واضح انه في العالم العربي يبحثون عن
الامن والتنميه بغض النظر عن النظام
السياسي والمشاركه مهمه استاذ عادل
الاستاذ منيف يقول ان العرب او الشعوب
العربيه تبحث في المقام الاول عن موضوع
الاستقرار والتنميه موضوع الاستقرار
والتنميه وهذا عكس ما ينادي به النخب
السياسيه ذات الخلفيات الليبراليه او
الديمقراطيه او الاشعريه او غير ذلك
الالحاح على موضوع الوصفه الديمقراطيه
صندوق الانتخابي حريه التعبير هل هذه
العناوين تهم رجل الشارع العادي استاذ
عادل ام يهمه الاستقرار والتنميه
هناك مثل صيني يقول بانه ليس مهما ان يكون
القط ابيض او اسود المهم ان يصطاد الفئران
وربما هذا المقوله تنطبق ايضا حول طبيعه
الانظمه السياسيه لانه يمكن ان تكون انظمه
ملكيه دستوريه ويمكن ان تكون تحقق نجاحات
وتقدم جوابا اجتماعيا واقتصاديا بالنسبه
لشعوبها وايضا هناك انظمه جمهوريه يمكن ان
تقدم هذه الاجوبه بكل تاكيد يوم ازمه
الديمقراطيه في العالم ككل وليس فقط في
العالم العربي ان هذا الشكل الديمقراطيه
ما بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه شاخ اليوم
اليوم ما نشهده من اصوليات منشد اليوم من
تساعد نزع شعبويه عن مستوى العالمي تطرح
اشكالات جديه فيما يتعلق بمساله
الديمقراطيه هناك اليوم نقاش كبير جدا في
الغرب فيما يتعلق بجدوى
الديمقراطيه وجدوى الانتخابات لان هناك
مواقع مختلفه للقرار ليست فقط الحكومات
والبرلمانات وبالتالي بكل تاكي المواطن
وليس فقط في العالم العربي ايضا حتى
المواطن على العالم الغربي هو يبحث
بالدرجه الاولى عن مصالح يبحث عن الامال
الاقتصادي وعن الامال الاجتماعي وعن
المستقبل بالنسبه لابناؤه وعلى هذا الاساس
حتى في الغرب يعني الدورات الانتخابيه
تقوم اساسا حول الاجور حول معدلات البطاله
حول كل هذه القضايا الاساسيه القضايا
الكبرى الان اصبحت وراءنا بحكم التحولات
التي عرفها عرفها العالم وبالتالي العالم
العربي لا يمثل استثناء في هذا في هذا
الباب العوده الى النقاش فيما يتعلق
بالمقارنه بين الملكيات العربيه
والجمهوريه العربيه هو ان هذه الملكيات لم
تتح لها نفس الفرصه لكي تقدم اجوبه حول
هذه القضايا ولا يجب ان ننسى ان اغلبيتها
يعني استثنينا بعض في السعوديه او المغرب
فاغلبيتها كانت في العشرينات من القرن
الماضي
كانت على اثر تفكك الدوله العثمانيه وفي
ظل صراع الكبير صراع الكونيه للاستعماله
والحضور الانتداب البريطاني وبعدها ايضا
كانت هناك صراع مع الاتحاد السوفياتي حلف
بغداد ومحاوله الحد من تمدد الاتحاد
السوفياتي الى المنطقه بحيث ان كل هذه
الانظمه الملكيه لم تنشا في ظروف طبيعيه
ولم تنشا في ظروف عاديه بل اكثر من هذا
مثلا في ليبيا اكتشاف النفط لم ياتي في
مرحله تساعد النظام الملكي لكي يظهر
النتائج الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه المرجوه
بل عندما وقع انقلاب القذافي استفاد من
الثروه النفطيه ولكنه لم يتم استثمارها
كما تم استثمارها في بلدان الخليج ولهذا
اليوم عندما نريد ان نقدم تقييم الملكيه
والجمهوريات هو هذا المستوى الذي تحدثتم
عنه فيما يتعلق الاقتصادي اليوم كل
المؤشرات لدي احصائيات
سنعود لكن مستوى العيش نعم احصائيات استاذ
عادل بعد قليل ارجو ان تكون يعني هذه
الاحصائيات ايضا بشكل برقي وسريع سنعود
لها بعد قليل اذا الامور مرهونه بنتائجها
الامور مرهونه بالثمار التي تجنى منها لا
يهمني مثل ما قال في المثل الصيني لون
القط ابيض او اسود يهمني
اتقانه للصيد ولما يتقنه القط عاده فاذا
المهم في هذا الموضوع ما الذي يجنيه في
نهايه النهار المواطن العادي امنه عيشه
استقراره صحته تعليمه وليست هذه الشعارات
انا لفت انتباهي ايضا انه ذكر الاستاذ
عادل انه النظام الديمقراطي او توليفه
الديمقراطيه اصيبت بالشيخوخه التي فرضت من
بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه ايلون ماسك
شخص الان يؤثر في العالم مثله مثل جوكر
بيرج
رئيس شركات فيسبوك اكثر مما تؤثر الاحزاب
السياسيه في الغرب يعني وهؤلاء اذا هناك
ميكانيزمات او اليات جديده السؤال هل
الانظمه الجمهوريه بدورها شاخت اليوم مثل
ما كانت الانظمه الملكيه بالامس ستهم
بالشيخ حي وهو النظام الامريكي
بالبراليه والنظام الصيني يعني النظام
الصين الصين نهضت باتفاق شنغهاي 1972 اللي
هو صناعه امريكيه وفتحت الجامعات فلاحظت
الصين بينماو وكشنجر ونيكسون ثم جاء دونك
وبدا التطور الصناعي هذا النموذج اللي
امامك الان اللي هو اقتصاد السوق
الاشتراكي طبيعه الحكم نقلت 300 مليون من
الفقر الى الغنى في الصين فهذا طبيعه هذا
النظامة هذه النظام الحكم لا تستطيع ان
تطبقها الحزب الشيوعي الواحد في الولايات
المتحده فدائما حسب طبيعه يعني انت لا
تستطيع ان تعيد الملكيه الى لانه انتهت
الملكات لانه الملكات في العالم العربي
كما ذكرتكم سابقا اذا هي ناشئه من بيئتها
وهذه دول محدوده يعني الدول الخليج
والاردن والمغرب خارج هذا الاطار فرضا
وبالتالي لا يستطيع نظام الشهر لم يكن
ملكيا هو رضا ميرنجي سايسخير اتى الدوله
القادريه ثم تحول العسكري رئيس وزاره ثم
انقلب والبس نظام موه لبوس الملكيه ولم
يكن النظام بدليل هذا النظام كان عاجز على
الاستمرار لو لم يعاد بعد ثوره مصدق
بالجبر
الولايات المتحده فهذه تعتبر طبيعه مثلا
تونس اول دوله في ما يسمى الثوره
الربيع العربي الان المشاركه التونسيه في
الانتخابات وصلت 11% بينما كانت وصلت الى
40% بالبدايه فانت لا تستطيع لا يوجد في
السياسه والاقتصاد نص ونظام مقدس يعتمد
على طبيعه كما قال موتو يعتمد على
الجغرافيا والمناخ والعادات والتقاليد
يهمنا العوده الى موضوع الارقام استاذ
عادل كنت توقفت انت عند موضوع المؤشرات
والارقام لا تكذب هي هي خير خير برهان
وخير دليل
[موسيقى]
صحيح لانه الان في لانه على كل حال فيما
يتعلق بتقييم الانظمه حتى في الغرب هو
النتائج التي تحققها على المستوى
الاقتصادي وعلى المستوى الاجتماعي هناك
مؤشرات فيما يتعلق مثلا سنه
2021 كانكشف المعاهد البريطوب عن تصنيف
الدول على المستوى الرخاء والازدهار في
المنطقه العربيه
وتصدرت التمارين الدول الملكيه الترتيب
ولم تكن اي دوله تعتمد نظام الجمهوري ضمن
هذه الدول الثمانيه ايضا في مؤشر
اخر يتعلق
بالامان والعيش في امان بالنسبه للدول
العربيه سنه
2022 تصدر الترتيب ثمانيه دول الثمانيه
الدول الملكيه ايضا ترتيب الدول في مؤشر
الصحه خاصه الفتره بين اغسطس 2020
اكتوبر 2021 كان في عز ازمه كورونا كانت
الانظمه
الملكيه ثماني الدول هي التي تتصدر
الترتيب بالنسبه الى مستوى العيش يعني
المدن التي يكون فيها العيش
تتوفر فيها كل ظروف العيش كان هناك تقرير
لاورونيوس صدر سنه 1922 كانت من بين 14
عاصمه 14 مدينه كانت مدينه تونس فقط من
خارج المدن الموجوده في يعني في الدول
التي يسدها النظام الملكي هذه مؤشرات هذه
مؤشرات حيه وهذه ارقام حقيقيه
وبالتالي لا يمكن لا يمكن الحديث عن عن عن
نتائج في صحيح انه في فترات كانت هناك
نتائج مهمه في عدد من الدول التي يسودها
النظام الجمهوري كما قلت بانه هذه الانظمه
على مر التاريخ لا ايضا لم يتحقق فيها
الاستقرار لان الاستقرار عامل اساسي تحدث
ضيفنا العزيز حول الصين الاستقرار عامل
اساسي فيما يتعلق بالنجاحات الاقتصاديه
وايضا فيما يتعلق بالحكامه وفيما يتعلق
بالقدر على اتخاذ القرار وعلى تنفيذه
اليوم مثلا سوريا عند ابن سوريا لاقدم
جمهوريه
عربيه يعني يمكن الحديث منذ 1932
يعني لما تعود الى التاريخ لا سواء
بالنسبه لسوريا او نسبه للعراق او لا
بالنسبه مسلسل من الانقلابات
يعني داخل نفس بنيه النظام وهذا الامر
بطبيعه الحال اثر على القدره على بناء
التراكمات على مستوى الدوله والتراكم بل
كانت هناك انظمه تذهب وتجيء ولكن
لم يتحقق
التراكم عامل حيوي مهم جدا في تعزيز
التجربه والاعتبار
او التصحيح النظر الى اخطاء التجربه ومن
ثم عمليه تصحيح مستمر هذا يقفله التراكم
والتراكم لا يمكن ان يتكون في حاله قطع مع
الزمن يعني الزمن يمضي حتى يحدث تراكم ثم
ياتي تدخل خارجا انقلاب عسكري غزو خارجي
اي عام اخر ينهي عمليه الاستمراريه ثم
نبدا من نقطه الصفر من جديد هذه نقطه مهمه
جدا وحقيقه انا لم اكن اتوقع ان كان عندي
ايضا محاور اخرى كنت اريد مثل موضوع
الجمولوكيه اللي هي المزيج ما بين الملكيه
والجمهوريه اللي هالمصطلح سعد الدين
ابراهيم اللي تحدث عنه اللي هو انظمه
موريس جمهوريه وتريد التوريث ايضا يعني
تاخذ هذه النقطه منها لكن لعلنا لنا عوده
استاد عادل لعلنا لنا عوده لهذا الامر انا
تفاجات صراحه الامر فعلا يستحق ان نقلب
النظر فيه اكثر من ذلك لكن الوقت
يداهمنا ونحن قبل قليل نتحدث عن اهميه
الوقت شكرا استاذ عادل بن حمزه من الرباط
شكرا استاذ منيف عماش الحربي من الرياض
شكرا لكم ايها الكرام والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]